I would have no description for the perfect volleyball player...
...'cause there is no such thing.
Every great player has different qualities.
Every part is being used in volleyball...
...but the big things that volleyball players need...
...are a strong shoulder for attacking and for spiking at the net,...
...certainly strong legs to be able to jump...
...and just as importantly, the ability to withstand the impact upon landing.
So, it takes a lot of integrity all through the legs...
...from ankles and feet all the way up to hips.
And then of course, volleyball players need a really strong core,...
...as in abdominal muscles, back muscles...
...and just because our core is the foundation of everything we do.
So, it takes the whole body to be a very good volleyball player.